We talked a bit about end-to-end encryption already, and
a lot of the assumption is that
we have some kind of symmetric key that we can use to talk privately.
So you and me have some kind of secret key and we use that to talk securely.
Diffie-Hellman is how we get that secret key.
Diffie-Hellman was first published in
1976 and has become
pretty much a staple for any kind of cryptography at all.
Whenever we use cryptography, we usually need to have a symmetric key
and to get that, we often
have to perform some kind of Diffie-Hellman. It's so prevalent
that your phone is probably doing it right now.
Right - when you logged on to the browser to watch this video,
you performed a Diffie-Hellman key exchange.
When you open up your phone and it connects to any server,
it'll almost certainly perform a Diffie-Hellman key exchange.
If not now, then in the next few minutes, right?
It's unbelievably important and unbelievably common.
The problem with Diffie-Hellman
is it's quite mathematically complex.
It depends on your level of mathematics, so what I've thought we do is,
I thought we cover the mathematics in the Extra Bits and then we'd
look at a kind of example of what actually happens
as an overview for those people who're just
not interested in the mathematics because they don't need to implement it and they don't really
mind.
Ehm, so we'll do both and in that way, hopefully,
there's something for everyone.
We shall see.
So perhaps Diffie-Hellman key exchange is slightly misnamed in the sense that
what we don't actually do is
exchange a key.
Because then it would be out
in the public and we'd see it.
What we actually do is exchange
some public variables and we combine them with some private
variables we've kept hidden, so that we can both create the same key.
Right, so we're actually creating a key together, in some sense.
So, as always, we'll go back to Alice and Bob for this.
So, let's have Alice over here,
and Bob over here.
I'm gonna sort of spread this out a bit because we're
gonna be putting these in and I don't wanna run out of space.
So Alice and Bob are here,
these are their own machines and this
is a kind of public area.
So anything
that Alice and Bob send to each other or agree on in public
is gonna be in this area.
So as an attacker, if we
want to break this key exchange, if we want to find out what the secret key is,
we have to do these variables to do it, right?
And that, hopefully, will explain why that's difficult to do.
Okay. So, the first thing is
right at the beginning of a Diffie-Hellman key exchange, Alice and Bob
will have to agree to some mathematical parameters that they're going to use.
This is a value "g", or generator,
and a big prime number "n", right. Now
for this example I'm gonna try and use colour mixing to try and explain
this. I'm gonna write the letters in as well.
n won't have a colour, for the sake of this analogy.
g does. So g is gonna be, ehm, let's go
with yellow.
Right now, I'm gonna sort of squirt this in and
hope that it doesn't go everywhere.
In fact, we kinda need two copies of g, really.
So let's just sort of fill it up here.
Up to about... I wanna get them the same.
So far so good, so far it's not all over my desk.
Alright, close enough. Alright.
Ehm, well it's kind of yellowy.
Often, they're shared at the very beginning of the handshake.
Sometimes, they're just embedded in the standard
or everyone always uses the same one.
It depends on the
situation. Ehm, it can take a little time
and an extra message to send these things across, so sometimes having them
stashed ahead of time is a good idea.
So we got g,
right, this is g.
Now, Alice,
to begin with, needs to calculate a private key,
or private variable.
I'm gonna choose red for Alice.
Here we go. I probably could have used more food colour than this kind of pale red.
Is that red? Yeah, close enough.
(To Brady) What do you think?
Brady: It's rose-coloured.
Mike: Now Bob is gonna do the same thing, he's gonna have a private value that is going to be blue.
Now, I haven't chosen very interesting colours.
That's simply because
there aren't that many colours available in the shops for food colouring.
Ehm, and I didn't go to that much effort.
There we go, that's blue.
Now, these two colours are in their private area.
This is "a" [red] and this is "b" [blue], so I'm gonna label these.
This is little a, this is little b.
Now, the important thing is that these are never shared
with anyone. Alice doesn't share this with the public;
Alice doesn't share this with Bob.
Now the first thing that happens is
that we need to combine the private key with the generator [g]
to produce a public key.
Now the point is that, once we combined them we can't
unmix it, right, that's why
people like to use this colour analogy - once we pour two colours together,
it's difficult to know what colours went in.
Because, yes, so if I poor red into yellow it maybe makes
orange, but it could be that it was a bit more yellow and a bit less red.
Or, you know, it's difficult to know.
So there's kind of
orange for Alice and Bob's gonna take
his blue, we kinda need them to be the same level really,
and it does kind of make green.
This is a bit orangy -
let's not critique me too much.
So, yeah, they're very different to the originals
and the important thing is that we don't know
what went into here, right?
We know g,
but we don't know a and we can't find out.
So this is actually, this public key here
is "ag", in some sense.
It's got an a in it, it's got a g in it.
This one has got a b in it
and it's got a g in it, and we can't extract
the a's, we cannot reverse this process.
Now, they then are gonna exchange these public variables,
but keep the private ones back.
So, we're gonna sort of draw an arrow over here
and an arrow over here and they're gonna switch them like
this.
So they get sent out in clear text-
These are now in the public area because they've been
sent in plain text, everyone's seen them.
So now, as an attacker I know
bg, or Bobs public part of this key,
ag, Alices public component,
and g and n, right?
I don't know anything else.
I don't know what a and b are.
Now, this is the final part of Diffie-Hellman.
It's not actually
very long.
You can do all this in just three messages.
Alice is going to take the public component that Bob sent her
and add her private key.
And Bob is gonna take Alices public component and add his
private key, so we're going to get,
in essence, a mixture of
a and b and g, right?
That's the idea.
So let's do that now.
Brady: So is that in the private domain?
Mike: Uhm, yes, this will be done privately because these are never exchanged.
So these go into the private domain now,
I mean I could make a copy of them,
let's not.
So Alice is gonna add her red in,
so let's go, let's just add some red up to about there -
doesn't really work because the red is really faint.
And then
Bob adds in his blue
which is gonna be like
that.
And hopefully, this is where it all doesn't work
or does work, these two values are kind of the same.
I mean they're not; they're pretty close.
That's a little bit darker, perhaps because the blue is a little bit stronger.
(Brady) Considering you've done that without actually measuring something -
(Mike) Yeah. I mean obviously, you would do this normally with mathematical -
err, mathematics -
mathematical functions that are much more precise than my random squirting
of liquids.
Now, -
(Brady) So those two are now in the private -
(Mike) These? Yeah, this is private.
So Alice has taken Bobs bg
and added her a, so that gets
"abg"; and Bob takes
Alices ag and gets "abg"
by putting his b in there.
Right. Now the order doesn't matter.
Remember, just like mixing colours, the mathematics
is such that adding b first to g and then
we add in a is the same as adding a first.
So these two values
are exactly the same.
If you wanted to try and
re-create this as an attacker,
you can't do it.
Because you have
ag and bg and g.
And, so you could mix these two together, and you'd
get "abgg", in some sense.
Mathematically, this is a little bit... tenuous
but we'll talk about that in the Extra Bits.
The point is, nothing in this public area can be combined
in any way to get
this value or this value, which are the same.
The only way to do that is to find out what a and b are,
and the only way to do that is to split up one of these two
public components, which is very, very difficult to do.
Alright. And that's what's so cool about Diffie-Hellman.
In a few messages,
we've sent some public
numbers around and
we've used our private numbers to get a shared secret that noone else can know.
Ehm, now you'd
generally do this at the beginning of every conversation,
and you would use this number combined with
perhaps some session variables or something like this to
derive secret keys to use in things like AES.
So this is actually just gonna be a number which will then hash
to turn into an AES key or something like that.
Now, the mathematics behind Diffie-Hellman is,
usually, modular arithmetics.
Recall that we have our public numbers g and n;
g is often very small - it's usually a small prime number:
n is often very big and needs to be big for the security
of this to work.
n is often 2,000 bits long,
or 4,000 bits is more common now.